WHERE DISHONESTY RUNS RAMPANT,
AND THAT MAKES THE FACT THAT
I FIRST THOUGHT HIS BUSINESS
WAS CALLED "GAY AUTO REPAIR"
THE LEAST OF HIS WORRIES.
HIS BIGGEST PROBLEM:
CUSTOMERS NOT TRUSTING HIM.
- I DO HAVE CLIENTS LIKE
THAT THAT ONCE THEY ENTER HERE,
THEY THINK THAT
I'M READY TO RIP THEM OFF.
- GREG SEEMED LIKE
AN HONEST MECHANIC,
BUT BEFORE HELPING HIM,
I NEEDED TO BE SURE.
SO I BAKED HIM SOME COOKIES
WITH SALT INSTEAD OF SUGAR
TO SEE IF HE'D BE HONEST
ABOUT THE TASTE,
AND THE NEXT DAY,
I PAID HIM A VISIT AT HIS SHOP
IN GLENDALE, CALIFORNIA,
WITH MY HOMEMADE TREATS.
- I HAVE A LITTLE
SURPRISE FOR YOU.
I BAKED YOU THESE COOKIES.
- FOR ME?
- YEAH.
- [laughs]
- SO FEEL FREE TO HAVE ONE.
- SURE.
- WHO MADE IT? YOU MADE IT?
- MM-HMM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
- VERY GOOD.
- YOU LIKE IT?
- I LIKE IT.
YEAH, A LITTLE SALTY.
DIFFERENT.
- GOOD ENOUGH.
THE PLAN: FOR GREG TO PROMOTE
THAT HE'S AN HONEST MECHANIC
BY ONLY GIVING ESTIMATES WHILE
HOOKED UP TO A LIE DETECTOR.
- I NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S--
- SOMETHING LIKE THIS WON'T
ONLY MAKE YOU LOOK MORE HONEST,
BUT IT WILL MAKE YOUR
COMPETITORS LOOK MORE DISHONEST
BECAUSE IT'LL MAKE
EVERYONE IN THE CITY GO,
"WELL, WHY ISN'T MY MECHANIC
HOOKED UP TO A POLYGRAPH?